we're going hello again welcome to part
18 we're getting writing that can be
actually cut yeah you're naked wire why
why are you naked assess yeah whatever
are you so blind that you see no cool
being me know or evil in a crib nope he
seems like the most normal person being
headless at all
oh okay no ma'am I doze alright let's
see
uh-oh hey ho that's cool there's
supposed to be some sort of portal ah
naked fire
I think that's protecting you because
it's not I'm gonna get you huh I didn't
even heard y'all I'm oh good yeah
spinning spinning oh oh
now right what's going on
Oh
ah yeah yep come on now oh come on
come on
you one more time haha nope not even
love it I'm gonna get you oh oh yeah
yeah
Wow oh shut up Alexander yeah cuz what
I'm about to do is perfectly normal
Oh nope nope too late BAM yeah I have so
what suck on it [ __ ] oh yeah yeah get
him ha ha yeah alright I win you lose no
hello rose petals again
there is uh huh do you see you Maya
no he deserves so much more no it
doesn't Daniel is a bastard
please don't do it I know you can oh you
can but don't what's going on
don't marry Daniel worry it will be all
right it won't
ah oh all right
that's it I made it oh oh no big deal at
all that wasn't skin
Oh like least scary game I've ever
played man Thomas grip Marga's
Johansson's and Lewis era Darrow Morales
that's an awesome name Park Nicator the
candor gens Nilson
yeah all right um yeah yeah honest -
honest honestly that was an awesome game
everyone should play that game if you
could make it through it cuz holy crap
that was awesomely scary honest
awesomely scary I'm gonna let it run
through the credits a bit
[Music]
I don't know just talking about stuff
you don't want to listen to me do you
yeah I guess if you watch my videos you
kind of want to listen to me
so I will be doing more Let's Plays I'll
be doing lots more Let's Plays I think
the next game I'm gonna try is maybe
Skyrim I'm not sure but oh oh yeah they
do have more uh I think these guys have
more games at penumbra penumbra yeah
penumbra I might try that one and
there's tons of custom stories I've
heard before and even so I might try
those too but I'm not just gonna do
horror games as much fun as it must be
to listen to me scream and cry like a
little girl but thank you so much guys
for watching I really appreciate it I
hope you enjoyed it and stick around for
more stuff it looks like the credits are
wrapping up here so thank you so much
for watching and stick around
dooba